myself years ago i went through like oh
my god it was one of the most
humiliating
humility humiliating episodes of my life
like it was so it was so dark
it was so dark that i
yeah i'm not going to say but i was in a
very dark place and it was so
humiliating but wallahi
i am telling looking back
and maybe on the day of judgement i'm
going to say to allah maybe i wish that
to happen a thousand times to me
because i'm telling if that didn't
happen to me may i was probably on a
trajectory that would have basically
destroyed myself and destroyed the dao
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
there was a guy who asked a chef he was
an atheist by the way how are you going
to feel if
you die and you find out that you know
there's no day of judgment there's no
heaven and how are you going to feel
and the chefs answered i'm not going to
feel as bad as you would when you find
out there is
hell and at the end of the day i'm not
saying religion is fear-mongering islam
is free-mongering but if you don't want
to have fear of a love your creator
and you want to be logically sold on
religion there's a lot of intellectuals
hamza zortzis muhammad hijab
there's too many people subur ahmed too
many great scholars too many great
advocates of the truth too many great
cosmologists too many great physicists
too many great
even students of knowledge like rami
that are just out here doing
their due diligence open your eyes and
insha allah god willing
you are guided to see the truth but
allah does not change the condition of a
person until they change what's within
themselves
so if you guys don't change what's
within you you're not going to get
allah's guidance you're not going to get
that
assalamu alaikum and welcome back to the
realist podcast in the dunya the three
muslims and today we're joined with
yours truly
hamza andreas zortsis
for the opportunity brothers
well yeah the pleasure is all ours to
find allah
um how you been bro good good
i can never complain alhamdulillah is
always
there's always things to be grateful for
i always say to people
anything above a heartbeat is a bonus
because we can't even be
grateful for individual heartbeats we've
had in a lifetime yeah
imagine trying to say alhamdulillah for
every single heartbeat we've had which
is impossible
first three years we kind of encount or
two years we kind of encounter when
you're sleeping you can't count
so you could not even say alhamdulillah
for each individual heartbeat
so imagine anything above a heartbeat so
anything above a heartbeat is a bonus
subscribed you to start
uh sapiens well that's a really good
question so
i was the ceo of the islamic well
it wasn't called the islamic education
and research academy when
i took over i think because there was a
bit of a rebranding but basically it was
known as
the islamic education and research
academy also known as iera that's the
official name
official name now iera so i was the ceo
for around just under three years and
then there was a strategic
shift and the strategic shift was to
focus
primarily on the kind of developing
world
and to focus on what you would call
roots or
maybe level one type tower and
therefore there was that strategic shift
made by the board
and then the idea came about to
basically for me to move over
to take all the great work that we're
doing in our era concerning the imams
and the masaif because ayer was also
known
as educating the activists the preachers
the imams the messiah
on how to give dao now obviously
you know the meshach and the imams are
above us but what we had we had a skill
on
we had a particular skill set and that
skill set was to be able to contemporize
meaning to make contemporary um
the islamic orthodox clash classical and
intellectual tradition
because we had experience we made
mistakes we tried to learn from the
mistakes we were engaged in
postgraduate education so we knew the
kind of
you know western if you want to use that
term western philosophical tradition and
so on and so forth
and so we basically uh trained them with
that in in in that context
so we had for example i think around 15
imams from canada to come down we had
imams and mashai from from the states
and we even had you know uh
mashayek from europe and we used to
basically give them
intensives and train and develop them in
order for them to do great work so
a lot of it was on atheism and
and general dao advanced dao so we were
known for that and all of that great
work and those relationships that we
built we didn't want to basically just
throw it away just because there was a
strategic shift
but don't get me wrong i think the board
in ira made a great decision
to focus on that on that tweaked
strategy
because when you focus focus leads to
success
so what happened was is um the idea came
about to
create sapience institute which was to
take all the great work that
ayer was doing in terms of the advanced
our training
and to basically you know inject some
spiritual and theological uh
steroids and just get it you know maybe
that's the wrong thing to say but you
know what
right just to give a bit of a boost and
basically um
to take to the next level so
alhamdulillah we just it's just been i
think
just over a year i believe and you know
we're starting to do what we've done
great work alhamdulillah we trained over
6 000 people on how to
academically and intellectually share
islam 6 000 people that's so long
i mean what i mean by 6 000 it's not
that we just had like you know a 10
minute
you know conversation but rather they
sat through our
you know our advanced our programs or
webinars or
courses and so on and so forth so yeah
so our aim
our focus is to basically
be the glue right so we try to be the
glue that sticks together
the kind of academic contemporary
academic tradition the islamic
intellectual tradition with people who
want to share islam
so we want to become that bridge or that
glue right and to stick that together
which is a hard thing to do because
sometimes you you don't know where
where to go sometimes you get too
academic that or you get too simple
or other times you get too popular in
terms of i mean by popular is not
likes and shares but you know the kind
of
um you know a popular narrative um
and so it is is a hard it is a hard uh
yani it's gonna be wrong words again
game to play it's not a game but you get
the point right
yeah so we're trying to find ourselves i
think we have found ourselves from that
perspective
so we've got some great things coming up
for example in the next
hopefully two weeks or so we have a book
that should be coming out which is on
divine perfection which is
being written by dr uthman latif and
that is a response to the kind of
christian world
especially the philosophical apologetic
world where you have academics
and you have a philosophical theo
philosophical narrative coming from
these
christian academics that say that the
concept of god in islamic tradition is
morally inadequate
because you know god is not
unconditionally loving
and therefore you know the god of the
bible
is far more morally adequate and
therefore should be followed and
believed in
i know that's a very crude kind of
summary but i think you get the point
and so we've responded to that
because we felt there was a gap in the
tower and i think it's very important to
fill gaps
you know we should do a health check
on the tower sometimes we just reinvent
the wheel and
sometimes we're not going anywhere we're
just like a rocking chair moving a lot
but not
not actually going in any anyway right
and and that's important so what does a
health check mean it means you know what
are the gaps in the dower
if anything's missing then fill the gap
what's unhealthy in the dour
then make it healthy by working with
other people or
trying trying to do it yourself enhance
it yourself
without trying to step on tolls and
bringing people together and
if something is working then make dar
for them and support them
or if it needs replicating then
replicate if
it requires replication so that health
check mindset is very important
and it should be used by all the
brothers and sisters involved in the dao
because i think it's it shows sincerity
because we're here to
make allah's word the highest we're here
to call people to follow subhanallah
with with mercy with compassion
and with hikma and with intelligence um
and and we want to do for the sake of
allah and if that's the case and i think
having that health check mindset is very
important right
um anyway so say pence's main focus is
to be that glue
is to create and develop and empower
people to be able to academically and
intellectually
share islam and all of our work is
linked to that strategy because we we
have a vision what's the vision the
vision is
we want to see a world that basically
receives the message of islam
and where people muslims are able to
share the message
intellectually and academically so
that's our vision and our strategy
is that we want to support develop and
empower people
to be able to share and defend islam
academically and intellectually
and that's where the the whole glue kind
of
i don't know is that metaphor the blue
metaphor comes into play that we want to
be like a metaphor
uh sorry we want to be like we want to
be like glue that sticks together
the intellectual tradition the academic
contemporary tradition the
the the classical tradition uh with
you know the people who want to get
involved in this work so
you know it's a balancing act but i
think it can be done and it's needed
and i think we have inspired lots of
people over six thousand al hamdulillah
and we're gonna do much more so one of
our targets before i let you guys talk
sorry
uh one of our targets is this year i
think to
er and empower and train and develop 10
000
people um so inshallah it can be done
and we've been very busy
uh filming professional courses for our
learning platform because
uh everything we do is free inshallah
and that's why we ask for support from
people because everything we do is free
so we're filming 10 professional courses
at least this year that's one of our
targets
10 professional courses to be put on our
learning platform
for everyone to access for free so they
could be empowered and developed so they
could share islam
academically intellectually masha allah
honestly may allah bless you and reward
you and everyone a part of this and may
allah allow you to meet and exceed your
goals because
a lot of a lot of us underestimate how
needed this is because subhanallah
there's a lot of the you know the
spiritual people there's a lot of the
heavily academic people
there are a lot of people that look
islam look at islam from a logical
perspective
and come to the conclusion that it must
be the truth and a lot of people that
will come to islam
from a very spiritual aspect and come to
that same conclusion
so subhanallah a lot of the time we make
it so black and white
like this is my way of giving dawah and
and we focus more
on sometimes showing that islam is a way
rather than showing islam is the way
and honestly it's it's amazing
masha'allah may allah reward you because
that is something that glue is something
that's definitely needed
yeah and just a point just to get people
to realize that
we don't believe that the only way to
give dow is through intellectual
rational arguments so when we're talking
about the
intellectual tradition we're talking
about
going into you know the quran and sunnah
and to understand how is it possible to
create awakenings within people
so human beings as we know in islamic
tradition we have a fitra
which is like the normative original
innate disposition
and that that innate disposition there
are two main opinions in the classical
tradition one is
that it's a natural disposition and it
has a form of knowledge like
proton knowledge you feel like primary
knowledge and that is knowledge of allah
he exists and he's worthy of worship but
it gets clouded right
you know if you look at the hadith in
sahih muslim when the prophet
alaihi wasallam said that every child is
born instead of
but basically his parents change him
that's the kind of paraphrasing of the
hadith
so in a way there is a clouding of the
fitzrah so
that's one opinion the other opinion is
that there is no knowledge in the fitrah
but it still gets clouded but the fitra
is like a vehicle
and if it's the windscreen is clean is
clear
then it could direct itself towards the
truth given all variables are in place
so what we want to try and do is uncloud
people's fitzrah to try and awaken the
truth within if you follow the first
opinion
or uncloud the fitzra to allow the fitra
to direct itself towards the truth
so the question what we try and teach
people in advance to our training course
is
there are different means to uncloud the
fitzra it's not just rational arguments
it's also getting them to appreciate
beauty so we have a thing in our darwin
training course
that the kind of reflection of beauty is
natural beauty by the way it creates
all and the studies show that when you
have or
your cognition is increased and your ego
is decreased
right and we know if you use your mind
properly the sound
the sound intellect it will come bring
you closer to islam
and if you have a lowered ego it will
bring you closer to islam right
because the ego is a buyer to divine
grace and mercy and so on and so forth
so there are different ways and these
means to uncloud the fitter can be used
in combination
or they could be used in isolation so
sometimes given
an understanding of the person you're
talking to you may realize
okay this person he wants he needs some
rational arguments
but my sensation my understanding of his
variables of his in
me individualizing him and understanding
his context he needs some
quran he needs some straight verses
right because
i sense a little bit of ego in this guy
he needs some of those heavy verses to
make him realize
who the hell are you okay no stuff like
that so
but that needs to be used in the context
of experience
in the context of you listening with the
intention to understand someone because
when you look at the sunnah
of dao when it comes to individuals the
sunnah of dawa
is to individualize the human being and
that means you come to him as a blank
canvas and you understand who that
individual is with his context
and that would make you realize what
approach you may need or what means you
will use to try and uncloud the
obviously this in the hands of allah and
the reason i'm mentioning this because
it makes the dao far more
mature and a lot of our art i think
unfortunately
not a lot of them but many of them there
is
there is what i would call some kind of
intellectual spiritual immaturity
when it comes to the doubt because
sometimes someone will throw through a
question
and it'll be an intellectual question
but they haven't assessed the individual
and they think right i'm going to give
them a philosophical answer
but then they end up having a useless
arguments and debates right
you know the famous hadith that we must
give up useless arguments and debates
right
and the reason it ends up in the useless
arguments and debates because the guy's
real issue
wasn't a philosophical problem yes he
acted a philosophical question or a
rational question
but it was a veil you know hiding
something else that was going on i give
an example
there was this um atheist that came up
to me
and he basically said oh and i'm
paraphrasing you know it was a while ago
an atheist came up to me and said oh
hamza your argument for god's existence
doesn't make sense right
and he who is an ex-muslim and uh it
doesn't make sense because causality
doesn't make sense out of the universe
now with all due respect
we could answer this we could say oh you
have an empirical presupposition that
you think
cause it is derived from experience but
we could show it's a priori
it's actually prior to experience from
that perspective meaning that you need
in order to understand your experiences
it's the first principle we're going to
metaphysics blah blah blah blah blah
but that's just ego that's just me
trying to prove that i'm clever or um or
that i'm right and they're wrong
because it's when you give down you
should give up your ego
from the point of view of always want to
be right always want to look good and
always want to impose
right especially if you're doing it to
the degree that you give up what's right
and you give up the truth that's what
you don't want to do
so um what i what i did was i
basically said to him what do you mean
by causality and our conversation
ended at that stage by him saying i
don't know
and i said to him because in western
metaphysics the nature of the causal
link there's lots of
right anyway then he said to me um
i don't know and i said to him well
isn't it very interesting that you're
using a key term
a key word in a sentence to reject god
you don't even know what that word means
and then i tried to you know be more
brotherly or nice to him i said come to
sit down and
after a conversation ended up a kind of
existential spiritual conversation when
he basically said
you know i didn't know how to connect
with god because my parents were secular
do you see what happened there so he
started with a philosophical question
but understanding his context and
understanding this approach and trying
to be
intellectualist virtually mature to
realize what is really clouding his
fitrah
it allows you to stand in the
possibility that there is another thing
that's going on
and that i think enhances the maturity
of the tower
and you see this when you look at lots
of online conversations
they're really talking past each other
or they ending they ended up just trying
to prove a
particular philosophical point and not
trying to create awakenings with people
because the process of sullen the you
know he was a message to mankind
not only from the point of view to show
that islam is the truth
but he wanted people to realize that
islam was the truth
those are two subtle different things
right if you're committed to the
well-being of another human being
which which what islam teaches us to do
you know
love for lynn has what you love for
yourself is hadith
bukhari sahih in tariq
yourself this is not the hadith that's a
hadith as well of course
but it says your brother yes and that
also means
brother in humanity yes there is the
muslim brother but there is also the
conception of
brother in humanity from the point of
view that you're committed to the
goodness and guidance
this is the explanation of anawi himself
and now he himself said this means
insania it can mean insane that you
committed to the the well-being the
goodness and guidance of people
even the maliki scholar even said the
same thing similar stuff
the point is if you commit to people's
well-being
you're going to start to think not only
do i want to prove that islam is the
truth but i want them to
have that awakening that islam is the
truth and those are two different things
so you could be arguing in an abstract
way and you may have proven to yourself
and prove to the audience
but you have lost that person because we
weren't committed to their
to their well-being um so i think it's
important
i'm not saying you know throw away
philosophical arguments i mean i wrote a
book about philosophical arguments yeah
i'm not saying
you know throw away the the the you know
intellectual arguments not at all
i'm just saying we need to be more
mature we need to be more aligned with
the quran
when it comes to dealing with
individuals because what is the human
man
we what's the human right what is the
human for god's sake we treat the human
being in a kind of
post-secular sense like the human being
is a function this model
is that you know in the philosophy of
the mind a functionalist model is what
is you have inputs and outputs in in the
philosophy of the mind
is is the human being like a computer
program you give them some kind of
rational algorithm and you expect some
kind of results
the human being is not like that we have
adopted a wrong understanding what it
means to be human
let's go to what allah is telling us
what a human is
a human is a dynamic interplay of the
roar
the
the intellect which is a function of the
the the nafs the ego the kind of
disposition
the and also the fitra all of these
things are dynamic interplay don't
forget the
what does it do there's wavering and yet
the akal
the rational faculties uh is in the
it's a dynamic interplay so when you
speak into the human being realize
not just a functionalist model you're
gonna give a rational argument you think
they're to accept stuff
that's a very very um immature way of
dealing with the human being
and i would argue that's why maybe
sometimes the dow is going around in
circles it's not moving forward that
much
because we've lost that we've lost that
you know we think okay what is down
to call to allah to call to the fact
that he is worthy of worship okay
so you have to quote for allah excellent
then we need to know who allah is
because you know who know what allah is
and how you're according to allah
then people think let's give down no no
the next step is
who are you speaking to who are you
inviting
that's important and we're missing the
big question in the dao today is what is
a human
and that would and if we understand the
human being as the human being is
as allah tells us what the human being
is the way we interact with them would
be
would dramatically change and you see
this embodied in the life of the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi he was sending look how all of
these doubt conversations
so many different kind of you know
scenarios
because there were different variables
different context he individualized the
person
everyone was different and everyone
required sometimes something else
because
the fitra was clouded in a particular
way so if anyone takes anything from
this is you know we need to be committed
sincerely to the goodness
and guidance of all people and that
means we want to create awakenings
within them
and that means sometimes we have to
stand in the possibility that what is
clouding the fitra is not only
issues about rationality but it could be
they need direct experience with quran
like factus name i think he's come on to
your show or your channel before
he tells me the story kind of spent
nearly 18
around 18 days with him just he left
about four or five days ago
um and he said that you know he was
speaking to some guy
he was an atheist or something he left
islam and there's all these
philosophical questions and after three
hours
fahad gave him quran and that's it the
guy came back
he was like when he told me this before
right so
everyone's different you know and this
is also in line with western cognitive
psychology because
you know people who claim to be like
really rational and rationalists right
uh that's just a joke because a lot of
the a lot of that rationality is
motivated or shaped by other kind of
uh emotive or psychological stuff that
they're not even aware of right
so yeah let's talk to the human being as
the human being is not some kind of you
know abstract ai
machine right anyway sorry for that rant
and narrative to apologize but
uh yeah so thank you for letting me talk
about secrets what about you guys
what are you guys doing may allah bless
you guys
i have heard good things about you i
have heard good things about you guys
you guys are the three real men right
on the online sphere
do you know what i mean before before we
go into that i just wanted to say
martial man like my mind is already
blown 20 minutes in
hearing all that and it really does put
a shift in my perspective that's what i
want to
get out there first and foremost that
going into it it's not just
rationalizing
a victim but it's connecting with
another soul
another fellow brother and sister and
beating them to the one tawheed
so absolutely that paradigm shift is
oftentimes overlooked and a lot of
people today just
outcome or you know result oriented
yeah yeah sure yeah absolutely
and yeah you know it's just it's
experience and you know it's not as if i
i
got into the dao with this mindset you
know my early days i was like you know i
want to prove the guy wrong i'm going to
show that islam is
intellectually superior and show him and
show how this person is weak
but that's actually not the sunnah it's
not the embodiment of rashma it's not
the embodiment of the sunnah to actually
deal with people in that way obviously
there's a difference between giving dao
to groups and into individuals and on a
social political level
i'm talking about individual one-to-one
dao from that perspective
um there are there are nuances in our
tradition our traditions like virtual
ethics meaning there are
variables that change the way we do
things or the way we
we react or the way we relate to things
based on the context
because we have a very rich tradition
more tradition like that but when it
comes to one to one
absolutely uh you know they're not just
uh
you know someone to direct your
intellectual
arrows right and you just want to like
annihilate them intellectually it
doesn't work that way you need to be
committed to their well-being
and that may mean sometimes giving up
the intellectual argument and buying
them a pizza man
you'd be so surprised or even saying you
know what i don't know
and through your humility maybe they'll
be like wow
islam it creates humble people i want to
take this a little bit more seriously
let me take this more seriously right
it could be through your behavior
everyone's different right and that's
why when you see
sahabah the way he became muslim you
know are you saying all the sahabi
became muslim because they had you know
theo philosophical arguments
come on man what kind of syria are you
reading
what kind of islam are you reading
you're making stuff up right don't get
me wrong of course they had your pain
conviction they had
high levels of japan for sure but we
need to assess and understand
um what is a human and that would make
you realize how some people you know
accepted islam for different reasons
other than purely
abstract rational arguments right yes
that's there
but we just have to appreciate the fact
that you know if you
do consider the fitra and you do
consider this as a first principle if
you like because it's not begging the
question because this is not
an argument this is a this is how do you
see the world right
it's so it's not about begging the
question because some people say oh the
fitzra thing is begging the question no
no you have misunderstood it
this is metaphysics this is first
principle this is the lens in which you
see the world right
um so if you see it that way if you
understand what i just said previously
you would make sense of the seerah
you'd make sense of the quran the
quranic arguments you make sense of
how and why people became muslim over
the past 1400 years
right but if you just see islam through
the narrow lens of abstract rational
arguments right
then you won't make sense of the quran
you won't make sense of the seerah
and you all make sense of how white
people became muslim for over a thousand
years
so we're not throwing the baby out of
the bottle we're saying just just just
unlock your prison man you've you've
imprisoned yourself theologically and
epistemol
epistemologically right epistemically
rather
unlock it and just free yourself
epistemically and you realize there's
much
more to the dower than proving this guy
is wrong and proving that i'm right and
proving that this argument
is the best argument but rather we need
to be sensitive to that and create
awakenings within people
yeah so yeah yeah it's amazing that you
mentioned that
oh no you want to go ahead rami's
rummy's being a little ball hog right
now
yeah i don't know it's all good it's all
good you want to go
every question such good discourses that
like i get more engaged so it's like
it's
listen it's beautiful so far so if you
want to go in i just got a question
that's all
all right i'll let me make my comment
first because it's not really yeah
i was gonna say it's amazing that you
mentioned um you know what is a person
right and what are people because the
person
people they haven't really changed
especially since the time the prophet
saw they saw them
right we haven't changed like you said
to be like computer programming
and and
change is the culture what changes the
time what change is how we interact and
we've
i feel like we've lost this
interpersonal connection relationship
especially with the introduction of
social media and everything
because it removes such a big aspect of
interpersonal
you know connection and we went from
seeing people's body language and and
being able to buy them a pizza like what
am i going to
go to a guy in the comment section and
doordash my pizza sound a lot like
it's it's you lose that aspect of it
subhanallah and it's something that's so
necessary
and when we live in a culture where you
know ben shapiro destroys you know xyz
uh at a college campus it's like
you're you're putting you're setting
yourself back as you said it's a prison
yeah
i was just watching before i came here
on here i was watching ben shapiro and
uh russell brand eclipse literally
it's funny you mentioned ben shapiro so
i was just watching it
and it's funny it's funny we're talking
about ben shapiro last night i was
watching
uh i was watching the baking video with
uh you and
sheikh fahad on on the tv and
bro i walked into the room because my
roommate was watching it
and i was like yo ahmed why are you
watching ben shapiro he's like what are
you talking about
and i was like bro say wallahi that ben
shapiro doesn't sound very
i don't say exactly but very similar to
shaq at the same time
i'm like oh my god i don't know why i'm
the only one saying but
do you guys not like hear that or
chocolate right no no no no no flour
flour flour no it's just flour
it's chocolate you don't put chocolate
and eggs everyone knows you put
chocolate what do you mean do it
it's chocolate what are you doing yo
it's not it's chocolate it's
not chocolate it is chocolate it's
chocolate spoon it's chocolate it's
chocolate look no trust me it's
chocolate
it's gonna be chocolate you gotta do
this it's always
part of what what drives the the sort of
obama-esque view
of how cuba ought to be treated as a
particular view of the united states and
its values
there's a view that that obama made
mainstream bro now hamza sources every
single time he hears
uh sheikh doesn't he's going to think of
that oh man
you know you know chef to fight to sleep
he is a phenomenal character man may not
bless him he is a
he's actually shaped me this whole fit
of stuff a lot of it was from him years
ago
really just you know give me that advice
even in a car journey when he came to
the uk and you know he really helped
from that perspective shape
our doubt so may allah bless him and his
family and grant them the best in this
life and and in the hereafter
and he's he's a proper man you know i've
gone to the gym with him and you know
just the way he interacts is
he's like masha'allah lots of confidence
and uh you know his uh alhamdulillah if
you chill out with him
one day you'll see you will see yeah he
can take control of social situations
and
you know he's he's a he's a he's a
intellectual psychological beast from
that perspective may not preserve him
yeah but yes so yeah
that was funny so you saw the cake thing
yeah you think we've gone soft yeah uh
you know what no i'm just playing yeah
you guys were good every every single
time i
see there's a thing like there's there's
a lot of stigma today
i don't want to take too much time
because i know angela had a question at
this rate anna's never going to be able
to ask this question
but there's a stigma today on men being
too concerned about what a man should be
that they're forgetting to just do what
a man should do yeah would be a good
question because i i was asked this in
ramadan i believe when i did a
instagram live about what is a man and
this kind of narrative
and i think you know when we say what
does it mean to be a man then you just
have to go to the best man that walked
on this earth which was the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and after
them
is after him was the sahaba right so you
need to see how they what was their
state of being
and this whole concept of madness
unfortunately the way it's been
understood not the way it's been
conveyed but the way it's been
understood in social media
is that being a man is you're going to
the gym and you could branch 170 or you
could
punch someone in the face or you know
you have confidence
now to be honest those are quite easy
things right you give me someone for
three months and i'll make them into a
beast for you yeah
right but if you give me someone three
months it's going to be very difficult
for me to do with the ego
and one of the greatest signs of to
being a man is having hill
forbearance and that was a sign of
prophethood to respond to repel by that
which is better right
it's easy right someone came up to me
and like spat on me
it would be easy for me to take that
person and probably just
just just crush them yeah just by virtue
of my size i'm like maybe 105 kilos now
you know relatively strong i have a
background in
wing chun i have a background in martial
arts and boxing and so on and so forth
you know say on average someone is not
like that it would be very easy for me
to
use that right but what would be very
difficult
is for me to hold my ego and react to
that person in a way that allah wants me
in that context
and one what i'm saying by reacting is
not basically just
the basics of the halal haram when
you're involved in the dao i don't want
to hear just
if you're going to be saying oh it's my
right bro then go away you're not needed
in the dao we're talking about the
higher islamic values right
the high islamic values because it is
true if someone hits you you can defend
yourself
absolutely but there could be context
in the now or in any situation that the
high islamic value
is not to react yeah that's how we
should be thinking in the dao
because look at the you know the famous
story
where the jewish man came to prophecy
someone pulled him by the neck right
pulled him by his collar the neck and
left the mark i believe
and one of the sahaba for he was at the
time he or radha allahu and wanted to do
something to him and the way the prophet
reacted was with him with his
forbearance
and we should be we should have haleem
from a human perspective
and so he responded to that in ways that
were much better
and the and he became muslim because he
was a jew that saw two signs of
prophethood he was looking at the
for the last sign and the last sign was
repenting by that which is better
and isn't it very interesting sort of
fusillax right
when allah says in the quran in chapter
in verse 33 chapter 41 verse 33
and who is better in speech
than the one who calls to allah dao does
righteous deeds
and says i am one of the muslims this is
the most holistic verse on dawah
you call to allah you do righteousness
and you say on one of the muslims like
you're linking your righteousness to
your submission to allah
that's the 33rd verse after that the
34th verse what does allah say
good and evil are not the same repel by
that which is better and between two
people there was hatred
it would turn to the intimate friendship
the
lemmas say repenting by that which is
better means
doing what is more virtuous and what is
more beautiful in that context
and there is no direct object after the
arabic word repel
it's not repel evil it's transgender
that sometimes translated like that
sometimes
but it's repel by that which is better
so in a way repel anything about that
which is better what is more virtuous
and what is more beautiful
so what we should do as men is always
ask ourselves this question
not just men but us human beings and our
sisters
what is the most virtuous and beautiful
thing for me to do
especially in the context of that we're
talking about yes there may be a time
that when it comes to halal and haram
my rights your rights you could play
that game
but if you want to get involved by being
an ambassador for the tower
don't start saying to me oh i punched
him back because i'm a man no you're not
you just you just said ego
you just said you said an ego monster
you just obeyed your ego
don't try and use islam to try and
justify your actions other than day if
you want to be an ambassador and truly
show how wonderful and beautiful islam
is and what it means to be a rajon a man
you need to have a sense of forbearance
yeah i see this story before i don't
know if you've heard it there was one
brother he was on a dao booth outside a
shopping center in london
someone a sister a lady came up to him
and spat on his face
he was smiling he didn't chase her call
the police he was my right i want my
dignity back or whatever you know
you know start complaining on on
facebook or social media
and we have some of our brothers that
are so expressive on facebook and social
media i find it very painful to be
honest i do apologize
you know the ones that are always
defending themselves i find that there's
a huge weakness i don't know why
maybe someone had been brought up or
maybe maybe it's my own ego allah knows
but i just find it
extremely weak when people defend
themselves because well bro give me your
address
bro let me tell you something i always
say that why don't you why don't you
defend align his messenger man forget
yourself
subhanallah who are you who the hell are
you you know
you're just you just you just you just
mean for that for that communication
defend
on his messenger forget about yourself
you know let people talk anyway
the point is yeah uh he she spawned his
face he took some tissue
he was smiling apparently he wiped his
face you took another tissue and gave it
to her
she walks off after maybe days or weeks
she comes back
she becomes muslim and after some time
they get married wow so let me tell you
let me let me tell you bro that's
forbearance repel by that which is
better between two people that was
hatred it would turn to intimate
friendship
and that's exactly what happened right
so
we have to look at the higher values
especially when it comes to like i was
speaking to a very famous
uh one of the duat right is i love him
two bits beautiful brother
but we had a private conversation so i
won't mention his name
i would say to him look allow this you
know social media
groupie thing everyone's trying to
defend themselves against other people
this is a this is very weak it shows a
lot of weakness
and it shows that we don't have
something good to say and it shows that
our priorities are misaligned it's all
about us as if we are the only
the only means to you know for the tower
no you just need that
you you know it's a huge blessing that
you even have the ability to even convey
the message of islam
we don't deserve it it's a huge gift and
and i just said to them
look i said to the brother you know do
you did you
do you defend allah his messenger in the
same way with the same energy
right i said something like that and you
know he his face was like
he took it seriously because sometimes
we we think
social media is all about ourselves but
it's not social media should just be
about allah
it should be about how we come across
how we relate to people
you know is it showing um is it showing
the best values of islam and i try and
do that on social media so
usually if someone were to describe my
social media i don't talk about people
i don't get involved in any kind of
craziness i try not to anyway
and yeah just promote the work that
you're doing say some good things
and all the other private stuff just
leave it for the private world
then you know just try and improve you
know the way you relate
uh to others using the social media
space in order for
you to represent islam in the best
possible manner it's not easy
but yeah so what was i saying yeah so
the whole concept of being a man sorry i
know we're going around in circles
we also need to talk about those egos
things as well how to suppress your ego
how to remove the spiritual diseases of
the heart the four main spiritual
diseases urgent
self-amazement hassad jealousy blame
with the jealousy
ostentation and kibber arrogance people
don't even know what
is right urjuba is like self-amazement
like you're not showing up in front of
people but you're showing off to
yourself you think that you
have an intrinsic ability oh look at me
i wrote that great tweet i wrote that
great essay
i did that great debate and you feel
that there's something really special
about you intrinsically and it's from
you
that's urgent that's one of the major
diseases of the heart
where all the other diseases emanate
from right the four major diseases all
the other
spiritual diseases emanate from from
those diseases according to
the earlier man so a lot of us have
urgent
but if you have any success in the dial
you do anything that is
good and praiseworthy it should increase
in your humility
and increase in your gratitude to allah
if it doesn't increase in your humility
and it doesn't increase in your
gratitude then we already have a
spiritual problem
now that doesn't mean we can't have a
sense of confidence and that you know
but it should be linked to allah from
the point of view that it's all him
right and we're just the empty tools
that he uses to manifest
his will and his mercy and it's not easy
how many times has
one written an essay or a paragraph i'm
like wow that's that's that's quite deep
man
right that's quite deep you know and
sometimes you forget who
did it who enabled it wasn't you that
threw
allah that through right behind
everything was allah there's no me
i'm great it only happened because allah
allowed it to happen
and it was a manifestation of his erada
his power and his kudra
so his uh his his will his kudra his
power
so you know the reason i'm mentioning
this is because yes we should talk about
a sense of being brave
because bravery is is missing if you
look at some of the islamic leadership
courses right or whatever you want to
call it bravery is hardly there i don't
think it's even mentioned right and
bravery is so important for leadership
it's actually a key pillar of leadership
and the person was extremely brave you
know when he went to the battle
and the arrows were flying and he was
like almost
on his own and he said i am not a liar i
am the messenger of allah
right and also when there was like a
noise in at night in medina
and the sahaba went to check what it was
they actually found the process on them
there
you know just trying to calm people down
he was already there
so the sense of uh bravery is very
important for sure but we
also have to talk about everything else
the characteristics
holding your ego having forbearance uh
you know
overlooking people's thoughts allah says
forgive and overlook don't you want
allah to forgive your sins you know how
can we claim to have any sense of
manliness when we can't even forgive
people man
and forgiving others is connected to
allah's forgiveness
allah forgiving you forgive and overlook
don't don't you want allah to forgive
your sins
right so those are important matters as
well so the reason i'm mentioning this
is because you know
all of you guys do great work we all may
love bless every single one of you
when we're talking about a narrative of
what it means to be a human
what it means to be a man as well is we
have to bring it holistically talk about
all of those things right
so you talk about the physical aspects
you talk about the sense of bravery
and courage you know a lot of us
unfortunately one one thing that's
missing in the tower is a sense of
courage and bravery but also talk about
the other things like the ego and the
spiritual disease of the heart
and having forbearance and forgiving and
that
and humility you know all of those
things are extremely important and that
gives you the holistic package you know
and there's much more to say on this
issue and and by the way
just as a caveat you know i'm just still
learning i'm still aspiring to to even
reach these things i'm nowhere near a
manifestation of those things i don't
need to think just because i'm talking
about that i am
you know the one who forgives and has
forbearance and no no no no no
i'm just saying this so it bounces back
to me as well so i don't want everyone
thinking that you know
you know i've made it and now i could
talk about it no no i i want to be free
of that hypocrisy okay
so it's just like you know us brothers
singing in a coffee shop and i'm just
you know expressing myself
and on what we need to where we need to
go with that narrative
uh but yeah so yeah may allah bless
every single one of you
i mean that was that was that was pure
that was real that's why we always teach
men on this channel that
real dominance is dominant being
dominant over yourself
it's having restraint it's not being
domineering or dominating towards other
people
it's about having control over yourself
your nufs your desires
yeah yes yes beautiful
we do need to do better you know husband
ourselves and myself
first and foremost so may allah allow us
to be you know men
similar to the falsehood still i said
them on hill bro before i keep going man
take the mic like 20 minutes later
you don't remember your question thank
you so patient
but first off you had said that uh this
guy
the woman spit on his face
and then she came back and he he she
became muslim and he married her
yeah masha allah he likes that freaky
stuff
allah bless him may allah bless him
but um the question i have for you
brother
the question i have for you all right so
you were talking about
the ego you were talking about um
uh clinton what were you saying
the fitra you said like the windshield
the unclouding
so in your opinion would you say that
uh purification of the soul would be
one of the ways to uncloud the feta
absolutely bro like for example in our
advanced our training course we have
this section on
spirituality for example um and
in that we focus more on showing to
people that the default position for a
human being is to be in a state of
worship
even if you reject god right because if
you
see worship as the thing that you want
to know the most love the most
obey the most or refer to the most and
the thing that you direct
extensive praise or ultimate gratitude
towards the most that's your object of
worship
so every human being has had an object
of worship even if they reject god so
what we want to try and show to them is
create that paradigm shift
that there is a deity that is actually
worthy of worship and
that deity is allah and then we explain
why allah is worthy of worship meaning
why must we love him
be humbled before him and we focus on
his names and attributes and so on and
so forth however
the the we also talk about for example
acts of worship acts of worship can
uncloud the fitra
when i became a muslim i wasn't just
intellectually convinced i had i started
praying before i became a muslim and i
remember one of my brother's friends
telling me
that when you're in sajdah you're
closest to your lord so speak to your
lord
so when i was praying i learned how to
pray before i became muslim and i was
praying and in sajdah i was talking to
god
right that was extremely transformative
for me
so even acts of worship i believe can be
ways to uncloud the fitzvah
and even one would argue you know when
people
explore the quran of sunnah concerning
how what does islam say about the ego
what does islam say about
ostentation what does islam say about
all of these things that could be a
means
to help people realize the psalms of
truth as well but it all depends who
that person is
as i said you have to contextualize it
individualize the dawah
someone may need intellectual arguments
and spiritual arguments together
in order to make that effective
cleansing of the fitra or the unclouding
of the fitra
but yeah so what you just said
absolutely there
there's like for example i remember one
of my brother's friends who was from
tablic
he said something to me he was like we
don't do things for you
for people we do things for god right
that was like such an alien concert for
me right i remember going to the
going into the toilet and i just my eat
my
stomach felt sick if i remember it was
like painful like oh my god you do
things for like
other than yourself that was such a
crazy thing for me but
that pain that i had was maybe necessary
medicine
to just break some of my ego in order to
understand that islam was the truth
right
so even concepts like this and so yeah
absolutely bro
so it depends so say you're talking to
someone who may he
they may already know that god exists
and the quran is from god but they need
something else right
something else is required you know
maybe you need to start speaking to them
about
the spiritual aspects of islam and what
mean by spiritual this kind of new age
you know secular understanding of
religion no we what we're talking about
here is
what does islam say about these things
what does allah and his messenger say
say about these things so when you
explore that
you're like wow that's that's extremely
powerful right
you know um and you know you know you
could give them like you know the
tradition on on
food and you know the prophet sallallahu
alaihi who
said like one of the worst things that
you know the son of adam can fill is his
stomach right
paraphrasing the hadith also concerning
the whole spiritual tradition of
what you put in your stomach is so
important and how much you fill your
stomach right
and and you know there is a correlation
between
your intake of food and your spiritual
state
right so even just talking about that to
someone who may like fitness or who may
like
food and you connect that to your
spiritual state and well-being
that might be a means to get them closer
to investigate islam a little bit more
further or at least to internalize
some of these things in order for them
to take islam more seriously
now when you talk about spirituality
other people they just need heaven and
hell bro
that's the final push for them and
that's that's missing out in the dao
as well which which are spiritual
concepts like hereafter unseen concepts
and it's a strategy of the quran
people want pleasure they want to run
away from pain and we miss that out
sometimes in the dial right how many
when was the last time you saw a famous
chef when imam tweet out something about
hellfire right sometimes not many do it
they do
but not many do it right um especially
when it comes to a non-muslim
perspective but maybe that's what's
needed for someone
because you know sometimes people need
that little push that spiritual push no
to take things
really seriously hey look you've had
enough i've given you enough
you know more things about islam than
most people you know
you know the quran is true you know the
person is the final messenger
you you know this is this is the correct
path in life but you're not accepting it
let me just tell you
if you count like this you're going to
go to hell forever right
and they'll be like wow and that might
just be enough for them
because i remember when i was in the car
when i you know i was praying
and i was already relatively convinced
intellectually convinced
my friend in the car actually just spoke
to me about death
and he did it in such a way that i don't
remember what he said
but i need i knew it had an impact on me
not in a kind of
irrational way in a way that the
experiences that i had with salah
and the experience that i had with the
intellectual tradition
just became real all of a sudden i knew
i had to make a decision now right
death is inevitable it's going to happen
and so
you know i remember texting him that
that night and saying
you scared you scared me basically
that's why i basically said to him
but not the kind of fear that i'm
running away from an enemy but i'm
understanding the implications now
so he understood what i needed at that
point right
so you use those things based on that
person's
particular context and this is something
that even al ghazali mentions
when he even talks about rational
arguments and he says you know
if someone's like emotional or
psychologically orientated
you're not going to give them like
abstract rational arguments this isn't
going to work for them yeah
or if someone basically is not even
ready even to understand those type of
arguments it might you might create more
superheart you might create more
destructive doubts you don't give it to
them basically you analyze the person
you help the person
um and you could only do that if you are
sincere
if you're sincere you know for the sake
of allah and you're sincere to the human
being that you're committed to their
well-being and guidance
then the way you relate to them is going
to be in that way you're going to listen
with the intention to understand not
only are you going to listen with the
intention to understand
but you're going to basically not
create any wrong lenses in which you're
going to
try to understand him so if someone
comes to you and says hey my name is
john i'm an atheist
what happens automatically is that i
have my limited experience of what an
atheist is
i have my own limited understanding what
atheism is i
and so on and so forth i take all of
that and that that becomes now
my filter or my lens in which to
understand john
and then i'm relating to john in that
way but who are you really connecting to
you're connecting to your drama to your
your lens your filter your limited ideas
and experiences you're not really
connecting with him
what we need to learn to do is become a
black canvas
and just allow john to be john as john
is
and for us to connect with him in that
powerful way and not only that and this
is another prophetic way of dealing with
people
is powerfully creating from the
conversation what does powerfully
creating from the conversation means
so someone comes up to me and he is like
a far right
hater of islam so the way i connect with
him is
i'm going to connect with him as if i
believe and i'm going to be sincere in
this that he is the best version of
himself
and i'm gonna talk to him as if he is
the best version of himself
and when i express myself in a way that
i believe he is the best version of
himself
i'm gonna get the best version of him
and it's happened before like we had
this
right-wing guy he said you want and he
swore
you want beep sharia law came up to my
face
and i was just relaying relating to him
in a way that was
i was powerfully creating from that
dynamic because i was basically
speaking to him in a way that didn't
represent his current state
but in a way that i was representing his
potential as a human being
and then he ended up hugging me right
so and that's a very difficult thing to
do right because sometimes the
initial reaction is to like you know
fight back sometimes we have to for sure
you know that's human nature there are
scenarios when
it's the most ethical and legal thing to
do but there are but most of the time
you can actually create powerfully from
that dynamic and the prophet sallam
you know one of the main reasons right
that khalid bin walid became a muslim
is because the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said how can a wise person
how can such a wise person not become
muslim
look look like the butcher of the
muslims right that's what he was at that
time right
he was fighting islam fighting or sins
but the process saying
how can such a wise person not become a
muslim
that's powerfully creating right and
that is something that we should do in
the tower and like for example
you know sometimes in the dow training
course we say to people you know
especially when we talk about rational
arguments we say in order for you to
understand the answer you have to
understand the concept of islam
and like i don't want the concept i want
yes or no i want you to know
so the way we respond is in this similar
way we say look
does yes or no really represent who you
are who i am as a human being
i know you came here sincerely to really
understand islam
and the answer is not yes or no what's
your name yes or no
what's your views on abortion yes or no
does yes or no represent you
so why do you think it's going to
represent me and i know you've come here
sincerely to interact me and get a
really
good answer the right answer in order
for us to understand each other but
do you wanna hear the concept of islam
then they're gonna say yes because what
i've done i've
affirmed that they're sincere i've
affirmed that they really want to
understand
i've affirmed that you know this doesn't
represent you or me
so i'm elevating them in the way i'm
expressing myself even though they may
not be like that
so um that's another very powerful
way of interacting with human beings as
well which is which is from the sunnah
and you know what can we do so i've been
talking too much man
everything is just sorry man one last
thing on my mind that i wanted you to
clarify
how does this john person form this
disparity between
okay it's i actually have to do the work
but then also using the excuse that
i thought allah only gods really wills
though so what if he's just not guiding
me
okay just repeat that again so yeah so
so people people oftentimes use the
excuse that oh god guides who he wills
right so
maybe he's just not guiding me so how do
they form that disparity between that
and draw that line between that and i
actually have to do some work too
oh so am i talking to the atheist john
here or am i talking to someone who
doesn't want to listen to islam because
this could be someone that's trying to
get on dean but they're just struggling
with enough or something oh and they're
basically saying like oh allah is just
not guiding me
yeah and they they they're like okay is
it me that's the problem is it allah
like
like what is it yeah well i mean the
most basic thing
to say to someone like that is that you
have been given a free will and
responsibility to take control over the
actions that you can control
and the things that you can't control
are things by definition that you can't
control
what you can control is you're learning
more about islam you coming closer to
the subhanallah
and and and you basically uh refraining
from haram and
you know doing the good these things are
within your realm of control so you say
to someone
is that in your role of control yes it
is or just
create a plan of action in your life in
order for that to happen
now for you to say metaphysically but
allah guys maybe allah has chosen me
i'm not the one who's guided and i will
just ask that person how do you know
did allah tell you you got some special
revelation that he's told
you that you're not guided okay where is
the revelation oh it's the quran so what
does allah say about guidance
yes allah says whoever allah guides no
one can misguide
right right you know the famous
statement
of the prophet as well and whoever allah
misguides no one can guide right these
are key principles from the quran
right and you say yes we agree with that
but
allah also says allah does not guide who
so there are there's a list of spiritual
states or
or or ways of being that allah doesn't
guide right
so you know allah does not like
so and so so when you see those things
are you seeing yourself
in there so if you're reading yourself
in those things then you know you now
you know
now you know now you know what you have
to change
so if allah says allah does not uh love
the
allah does not guide the arrogant for
example then you know and then you feel
that you could see that within yourself
then you got something to work on right
so
from that perspective you know when
people use that uh
kind of get out clause yeah you know i'm
doomed allah has misguided me you're
like well
how do you know hey you go in your
special revelation
the angel come down to you and say hey
you're the misguided one no of course no
and what's really funny is when you look
at the quran sunnah
you're gonna be taken to account for
that
attitude because we know we have free
will we have the sole responsibility
uh with regards to things that we can
control which is our own
the way we relate to ourselves our own
states of being and
uh you know and that's what we need to
understand yes of course allah guides
and no one can misguide those who allah
guides
but that's in the realm of you know the
metaphysical the realm of allah if you
like right
when it comes to us we have
responsibility and accountability the
quran spends a lot of time in talking
about accountability and
and you know assuming that
responsibility and free will that we
have
but when you break it down further and
you see okay well who does
allah love who does allah not guide
okay is these type of states these type
of
ways of being okay do i have that
well if i want allah's guidance then i
need to start focusing on my ego
i need to start focusing on my purity i
need to stop focusing on this that and
the other
do you see my point so um
you know you can't read the quran one
way and dismiss everything else
because yes allah says that guidance is
solely in his hands
but allah also says that you have free
will to make the choices that you need
to make
and allah also says that allah doesn't
love the doesn't like the list of these
people
and allah doesn't guide so so on so and
so and so and so
people who are arrogant and so forth and
so on and so therefore you know now what
you need to do
to be in in the kind of uh
in you now know you now now you know
what you need to do to actually be
enveloped in allah's special love
and actually be eligible for guidance
right it's all there in the quran for
you
right um so i've never heard an atheist
say that to me before
personally from what i remember but
muslims actually say that a lot i think
sometimes right and especially the ones
who have gone a little bit straight
and they've lost hope and they're like
you know i'm doomed allah has you know
misguided me
but you know you have so many beautiful
stories or in our tradition
where people had like crazy lives and in
the end or
halfway through the adult life they made
a huge impact
i believe there's a famous story of a
drunkard and he was drinking lots of
wine i believe and there was a famous
person
a scholar of hadith or something and the
drunkard came to him and was pestering
him and
wanted a hadith for him from him or
asked him a question or something and
the the scholar actually responded by
saying the the hadith of
you know if those who don't have no
shame they could do whatever they want
that hadith right obviously i'm
paraphrasing paraphrasing hadith
and then that affected him so much that
he broke all his wine bottles i believe
and then uh that person eventually
studied hadith and he was the teacher of
bukhari
there's a gap between us and how much
how close we feel to allah if you feel
that gap widening and widening and
widening allah didn't move
so you have to ask yourself who really
moved yeah i heard the
web say that it was very powerful on a
thing on his instagram
he was like who moved and let me tell
you what's beautiful
there we talked was beautiful adam
scenario is one of the most moving
powerful beautiful scenarios you can
ever imagine
i want you to think about this yeah and
this is so in in contrast to the
christian tradition
in the christian tradition god is so
holy sin
breaks the relation with man and and and
you need some kind of blood sacrifice
right
so there's no direct forgiveness
forgiveness is not contingent on the
relationship between god and his servant
it's contingent on some kind of blood
sacrifice and that's where you have the
kind of jesus narrative of him being
um sacrificed right
but look at the islamic tradition allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala doesn't describe
what happened with
um with adam alaihissalam
as a fall he describes it as a slip
right so the adam and eve story it's not
a fall from grace it's a slip it's
described as a slip in a quranic
narrative
not only is it described as a slip but
what does allah say
and this is actually quite moving allah
says
and we turned and we turned
right and we turned to them because they
moved away right
so it's like a you know from a kind of a
metaphysical spiritual sense and we
turned and taught them words of
forgiveness
and they repeat those words and allah
forgave them
you know the famous alumni
and that is so beautiful because they
made the mistake they make the slip
not only allah is so maximally forgiving
that he forgave them but he turned to
them to teach them words of forgiveness
that is so beautiful because
if you contrast with the christian
tradition the very fact that
god created man and he knew man would be
weak and
that and man would be weak and his
weakness now breaks the relationship
totally
that god in the christian tradition
can't even forgive him directly
and this is why we say allah is
maximally loving in the islamic
tradition his name is
the loving and he's maximally loving
because he is maximally forgiving you
cannot be
maximally loving if you're not maximally
forgiving
meaning your forgiveness is not to the
highest degree possible
so how can they say god is maximally
loving in the biblical sense
when he is not maximally forgiving
he's too holy he can't forgive him
straight away
the forgiveness is not based on the
direct relationship between
god and his servant forgiveness is based
on something external to the
relationship
right but allah he turned
to adam taught him words of forgiveness
and forgave them is based on the just
turn to allah just
repent to allah so um
this is why um i don't know why we spoke
about this well we're speaking about
forgiveness i forgot
why between uh the disparity between
blaming allah and
you know stuck for love and saying you
know is allah is not guiding me and also
taking responsibility for your own
actions
yeah but i forgot why we got into this
there was something i forgot
but anyway it was good anyway the thing
is it's power it's a powerful narrative
um and uh and this is
the stuff that we're talking about in
the divine perfection book obviously we
unpack it
in in detail that's one of the things
that we talk about because you know
how can you say you know this crea this
deity that you believe
in the conception of the deity that you
believe in in a particular
spiritual tradition is supposed to be
maximally loving meaning
loving to the highest degree possible
but it is not maximally forgiving
because forgiveness is actually a
language of love uh and if you're not
maximally forgiving
can't be maximally loving imagine for
example you have a servant
under the king's castle and he made a
mistake and he goes to the king and says
look i made this mistake and the king
says
you know i can't forgive you the only
way i can forgive you if i basically
um kill torture my son
is that and then the other scenarios and
servant makes a mistake in another
king's
court or palace and he turns to the king
says look i'm sorry i slipped up i made
a mistake
and the king says don't worry if you say
this i'll forgive you don't worry
what what two scenarios are more or are
a manifestation of forgiveness
right the first scenario the second
scenario is the second scenario
uh and obviously with with only with
allah is the greatest example
and we're not making an analogy with
but by allah reason um allah is
his maximum forgiveness because in the
islamic tradition when we talk about
talheed we talk about the wonders of
allah's names and attributes as well
and when we talk about the wonders of
allah's names and attributes we
basically say that allah's names and
attributes are transcendent
but also we say that they are to the
highest degree possible without any
deficiency in any flaw that's what it
means by maximally
maximal perfection to the highest degree
possible
so when we try to conceptualize our lost
forgiveness in this context
we say allah's forgiveness is to the
highest degree possible
and you could just create these thought
experiments when you look at the
biblical
kind of adamic conundrum and realize
that this is not
the expression or the manifestation of a
maximally
forgiving lord because he couldn't even
forgive adam right
and then he just continues from there so
anyway oh yeah so this was a jam-packed
episode
yes guys if you made it before before no
no
no no no yeah they finished the question
because we
we started with answering his questions
or somewhere else
so you would say then that if someone
experiences low iman
it's because of the ego
no i'm not i'm not saying that
necessarily um
not at all it could be it could be but
when it comes to those situations
you know we can't generalize we have to
understand you know what is
the why look having low iman is a
natural part of one's spiritual life
right and we know to increase one's iman
what do we do
we increasingly know good deeds as well
we're increasing our vicar
we get to know allah more right because
the whole kind of dynamic of what iman
is
right so you know the more vicar you do
the more spiritual practice you do the
more good deeds that you do and the more
knowledge that you gain
and the more knowledge of allah
subhanallah that's going to increase
your iman right
so sometimes when our iman is down is
maybe because we've been we've moved
away
from the zika or spiritual practice or
we've moved away
from some good deeds that we're supposed
to be doing
um and and so on and so forth but we
can't necessarily say it's because oh
they've got an ego no no no not at all
because in the grand cosmic scheme of
things sometimes
today's low iman could have been such a
blessing because it
pushed you to the next level right
because sometimes you know you know you
know especially when we're engaged in
like
you know the dikka in the morning and
the evening the hajjard and the
recitation of the quran and so on and so
forth we get into this kind of
mechanistic way of being
and we think it's us now look what i'm
doing i'm the boss i'm the man
right and that becomes a spiritual
disease of right
so maybe then allah makes you drop to
make you realize this is all from allah
and that i should be grateful every time
you know i have been given any
opportunity to connect with allah
i should be grateful and and know that
it's all because of allah
because remember the more closer you
become to allah and the more good deeds
that you do the more you should realize
this had nothing to do with you in the
first place
right but if you increase your uh your
good deeds
and you think it was intrinsically
because of you but that is a sign of uh
a sign of one of the spiritual diseases
and maybe out of allah's love
he'll make you crash a bit and you'll be
like i feel really bad
uh just to create the awakening within
you that this
this was because of allah the the very
fact that i could pray more was because
of allah
the very fact that i could glorify allah
was because of allah the very fact that
my iman was high was because of allah
and i am going to be humble and even
more grateful
if by the will of allah allah elevates
my iman and i'm going to try and move
forward in that way
so maybe sometimes looking back into
your past thinking you know my iman
was so crushed it's because allah loved
you bro well and i loved you and he
wanted you to create have those
awakenings right
like myself years ago
i went through like oh my god it was one
of the most humiliating
humility humiliating episodes of my life
like it was so it was so dark
it was so dark that i
yeah i'm not going to say but i was in a
very dark place and it was so
humiliating but wallahi i am telling
looking back and maybe on the day of
judgement i'm going to say to allah
maybe i wish that to happen a thousand
times to me
because i'm telling if that didn't
happen to me may i was probably on a
trajectory that would have basically
destroyed myself and destroyed the dao
and i'm looking back although it was one
of the most darkest episodes of my life
right really dark yeah because it was
really
it was it was quite dark um and i was
really down
and but looking back if that didn't
happen to me
because you know everyone's different
sometimes a scholar would
would teach you and train you and help
you sometimes
it'll be people around you but for some
people allah has to be
the one giving you the table uh
for someone as egotistical as me i think
uh
maybe you know a lot just basically just
put me into place
uh and that is what is you know and the
reason i'm mentioning this is not just
to show that look oh you know i've had
these experiences too
no well that's one of the reasons but
the main reason is to show that
you know when you look at your trauma
when you look at negative experiences
sometimes those experiences especially
if you have good
good opinion of allah you have
bella you have good opinion of allah and
you want to come closer to allah
and those experiences when you look back
were probably the best thing that ever
happened to you um
so things like low iman things like
humiliation things like
whatever it could be stand in the
possibility that the meaning you're
giving to
giving it is not the meaning that allah
wants you to give it
because when you have any trauma in life
and i know it's very easy to say because
we're relatively have easy lives but
when you have any trauma
it's a small t trauma or a big t trauma
one of the ways of dealing with your
trauma is to stand in the possibility
that the meaning you're giving it is not
the meaning allah wants you to give it
and that can only happen really if you
have hasana
if you have good opinion of allah and we
know that the way we react to these
tests
in life is a sign of his his love
or a sign of his you know that he's
trying to wake you up
um so we have to react in the most
appropriate way and give it the right
meaning
and we see this with you know sort of
when allah talks to
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
like you know when you you know we
guided you you're an orphan and we took
care of you so allah is giving the
correct meaning to those past events
to the prophet sallallahu alaihi he will
send him similarly
you know uh when he's talking about
muslim talk about you know who inspired
your mother to put you in the river and
so on and so forth
so allah is giving the correct meaning
to these events
in order to create a state of being from
the person in this case the process
in order for them to move forward in a
positive way so likewise what we need to
do is try and stand in the possibility
that the meaning that we're giving our
trauma or negative experiences is
actually not
because i hit low man i was like
you know i was like yeah i was like
you know allah doesn't love me or allah
doesn't want me to do the dawah or
you know you know everything i've done
has maybe has been because it's
this it's all wasted there's no
sincerity in my dial
oh man i hit low if you don't if you
feel comfortable sharing it
is it after islam yeah and i was muslim
bro
i was muslim i hate what are you talking
about this was not this was not like a
jahilia thing no no i hit really low bro
it was it was yeah
absolutely it was ex you know and you
all credit to my family
my wife picking me up you know and you
know when people see me on social media
they think nah hundreds are going to go
through stuff like that
well i did and you know it happens to
everybody right
um and i definitely needed it absolutely
i don't think i would have been able to
manage iera
or help manage sapin's institute or
really try and focus on other people in
the dawah
if i didn't go through that humiliating
experience um and it was one of the best
things that
probably ever happened to me from that
perspective and maybe
maybe maybe more is coming you know may
allah protect us but
you know you know you always have good
opinion of allah remember once god is
saying this to me i we're walking near
my house
in the hilly park on the grass mama
bless the sheikh
he said to me listen hamza you know
maybe
something like this on the day of
judgement you're going to wish that this
happened to you a thousand times
um and he talked to him about his own
experiences as well that he had a very
tough experience in
with regards to you know a relationship
with the brother
in terms of the it was to do with i
don't know business or something and
that really affected him and
people spoke and you know that it was
humiliation there
and this that and the other but those
are things for you to grow
you know if you always have a good
opinion of allah
even if you think you deserved it you
know that even if you think you deserved
this kind of wake-up call or you
deserved it because of your sins or your
ego your arrogance
never give up hope in the mercy of allah
never
give up the kind of good opinion you
have of allah
because even if he did deserve it then
allah is taking care of him he's trying
to
wake you up he's trying to say look i'm
doing this to you because you need it
if you don't have this you're not going
to have the correct state you're not
going to change your state of being
to come closer to me so my love for you
is i'm giving you this humiliation i'm
giving you this event i'm giving you
this trauma
in order for you to elevate yourself and
you're going to realize that later
but have a good opinion of me so i think
one of the basis of keeping your iman
is always have a good opinion of allah
always
um i think you've been tamiya says
something of of
the similar similar lines about you know
you know i think those who leave the
dean or those who you know
leave the dinners because the basis of
it was they didn't have a good opinion
of a lost panel at all
so that's very important yeah always
have
husson of unbella and you're gonna see
even now
you guys might be i don't know how old
you are but look at back just try and
connect some of the dots and you were
like yep
yep yep yep right and that's it and then
just give it the right meaning and then
move forward i know it's easy easy to
say
it's not easy in reality but if you have
good people around you
you know you could uh you could uh you
could you could you could give the the
right meaning to to
to these types of traumas they're very
important so and that's what we teach in
the course by the way
in the advanced our training course in
when we talk about experiences
getting people to understand their
spiritual experiences their negative
experiences
and even the positive experiences in the
way that allah
wants them to give it even if they're
non-muslim because that could be a means
of doubt
because when you reading the quran you
should teach people
that you would find yourself in the
quran right guaranteed
you will find yourself in this book and
when you look at experiences
and you see the meaning that allah has
given to some of these experiences
you be like okay well maybe the meaning
i'm giving
i'm giving to this trauma or the meaning
i'm giving to this experience or the
meaning i'm giving to this positive
experience
is not the right one like for example
you know a lot of atheists and
non-muslims
they have successful lives they become
rich and wealthy
right so what is the what meaning does
allah want to give them
is it the meaning that they that is like
oh it was all me i'm successful i did
this
i did that um you know all my hard work
and you hear these narratives right on
social media it was my hard work it was
all
me and this that and the other but allah
wants to make them to understand that
every blessing
is from allah which would increase one's
humility and one's gratitude
and if you're grateful allah will give
you more give you more to be grateful
about
right and so on and so forth so there's
a different paradigm of seeing wealth
and success
because the true successful one is to
realize that his success was actually
from allah subhanahu wa to allah not
himself right
and that would be maybe an unveiling for
them to come closer to the deen
so when someone's reading the quran or
understanding some people need that
right they don't like the intellectual
stuff they just need right what is the
right meaning i must give to these life
events
and when they look into the quran they
find themselves in the quran and they
find the right meaning
then that could create a massive
awakening for them right
so yeah
you know you know what i mean i never
thought it was like that that everyone
can find themselves in the quran
guys smash the like button if you made
it this far look forward to our next
episode with brother hamza
swordsis on fitness and martial arts you
want to give them a teaser before we
wrap this one up that a lot of people
might not know that you do martial arts
or did martial arts yeah yes so
i i was trained in wing chun kung fu and
my chain of transmission is myself hamza
moyulon also known as sifu ah lemos
and he was taught by more yat and
moriyat was taught by
ip man himself so that's wing chun i
dabbled in steel
wire mantis i did boxing for a long time
as well
and other bits and pieces so yeah i've
been dealing with this stuff for a while
and there's a lot of spiritual lessons
to learn from training which we can
unpack in the next episode
all right guys comment down below
hashtag bring hamza back
and look forward to next time hashtag
spit in my face
don't do that guys good job bro i gotta
cut that part out
why you gotta cut that out come on bro
all right end it up bro it's unbefitting
allah and with that being said
assalamu alaikum
don't you know that islam forgives
everything you think it's the tattoo
that's stopping you do you think it's a
jihadi that's stopping you
or is it you sincerely turning back to
allah
is it you having the humility to own
your mistakes and say allah
i'm ready to come to you allah i'm ready
to start fresh allah
let's make this happen let me submit to
you ya rabi
because i was wrong but now i'm ready to
write my wrongs which one is it
because allah is ready to forgive you
the question is are you ready to ask for
that forgiveness
there was a guy who asked the sheikh he
was an atheist by the way how are you
going to feel
if you die and you find out that you
know there's no day of judgment there's
no heaven and how are you going to feel
and the chefs answered i'm not going to
feel as bad as you would when you find
out there is
and at the end of the day i'm not saying
religion is fear-mongering islam is
fear-mongering but if you don't want to
have fear
of a love your creator and you want to
be logically sold on religion there's a
lot of intellectuals ham desortsis
muhammad hijab
there's too many people subur ahmed too
many great scholars too many great
advocates of the truth too many great
cosmologists too many great physicists
too many great even students of
knowledge like rami
that are just out here doing their due
diligence open your eyes
and insha allah god willing you are
guided to see the truth but allah does
not change the condition of a person
until they change what's within
themselves so if you guys don't change
what's within you
you're not going to get an allah's
guidance you're not going to get that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um